en los vídeos pasados ya platicamos como
al desplazar la curva de demanda
agregada hacia la derecha esto causa
inflación a eso se le conoce como
inflación de demanda o bien como
inflación por exceso de demanda va lo
que quiero hacer ahorita es estudiar qué
sucede si la curva de oferta agregada a
corto plazo se desplaza hacia la
izquierda eso también va a causar un
cierto tipo de inflación que se le
conoce como inflación inflación
de costos de costos costos salen
entonces para estudiar esta inflación de
costos de nuevo vamos a dibujar nuestra
gráfica aquí tenemos precio agregado un
precio que indique a nivel
macroeconómico qué tan caras están las
cosas y de este lado tenemos el producto
interno bruto real producto interno
bruto real en esta gráfica me interesa
poner la demanda agregada acordémonos
que demanda agregada es así con
pendiente hacia abajo ya platicamos
porque en los vídeos anteriores y
también me interesa poner la oferta
agregada a corto plazo entonces la voy a
poner más o menos
de este estilo
- así
y a lo mejor todavía no te platicado
porque la pendiente cada vez va
aumentando más y más pero tiene que ver
con lo siguiente o sea al principio es
muy fácil convencer a la gente que no
está trabajando de que trabaje porque
está desempleada y necesita dinero pero
si la gente ya está trabajando mucho
entonces es muy difícil convencerla de
que tenga que trabajar más o sea es más
fácil pasar de que las personas no
trabajen a que trabajen a pasar de que
trabajen a que ahora sus días de
vacaciones también los trabajen verdad
de modo similar las máquinas al
principio pues no hay que forzarlas
demasiado pero después si ya están
trabajando al 80 90% entonces aquí este
pues no hacer más mantenimientos hacer
más supervisión es y por lo tanto un
cambio de producción acá arriba produce
un mayor cambio de precios que un cambio
de producción acá abajo sale voy a poner
algo así aquí es un pequeño cambio que
hace un pequeño cambio en los precios
pero aquí ese mismo cambio
ese mismo cambio hace un cambio más
grande de los precios bueno por eso esta
gráfica tiene digamos en términos
matemáticos una pendiente más y más
positiva
dejale pongo que es la de oferta
agregada a corto plazo muy bien ok
entonces lo que lo que quiero hacer
ahorita es ver qué sucede si esta
gráfica de oferta agregada a corto plazo
se desplaza hacia la izquierda vamos a
ver qué sucede voy a pintarla en color
rosa
así desplazándose hacia la izquierda
digamos algo como de este estilo
entonces vamos a pensar que se mueve
hacia acá ahorita vamos a platicar qué
bueno por qué tipo de razones podría
desplazarse hacia la izquierda si
entonces se mueve para la izquierda esta
es una nueva oferta agregada a corto
plazo y que sucede mira qué pasa con los
niveles de equilibrio antes los niveles
de equilibrio lo voy a pintar por acá
antes teníamos un cierto nivel de
producto interno bruto real
a esta altura y un cierto nivel de
precios a esta otra altura algo más o
menos de este estilo sí pero al
desplazarse esta curva hacia la
izquierda
este producto interno bruto real
disminuye y los precios aumentan
entonces esta de acá es una inflación
todavía peor que la de demanda agregada
verdad cuando desplazamos demanda
agregada hacia la derecha cuando
desplazábamos demanda agregada hacia la
derecha pues qué sucedía esta curva la
naranja se movía para cada el producto
interno bruto real aumentaba y el precio
también aumentaba lo cual pues estaba
más o menos razonable verdad porque pues
se iba produciendo más en la economía y
lo que sea pero aquí pues que pasa esta
curva se mueve a la izquierda el precio
aumenta pero el producto interno bruto
real disminuye entonces eso está más
grave verdad bueno en cierto sentido a
lo mejor esto lo has escuchado con otro
nombre también se le conoce como como
estanflación lo voy a escribir aquí al
lado
estanflación está
la acción estanflación es una
abreviación de estancamiento
estancamiento con inflación o sea
aumentan los precios pero la economía
está estancada y hay dos ejemplos
recientes en la historia de eeuu o bueno
en la historia mundial de hecho porque
el petróleo es algo mundial de este
fenómeno de acá y el primero es de 1973
1973 y tiene que ver con un embargo
petrolero
sin embargo embargo petrolero petrolero
en este embargo petrolero con varios
países que forman parte de la opep pues
decidieron así ya no surtir el petróleo
a eeuu ya otros países que apoyaron a
israel en la guerra del yom kipur si
entonces este esto causa una crisis
petrolera y una segunda situación en la
cual este hubo algo de este estilo fue
en 1979 donde fue bueno en fecha en la
cual fue la revolución de irak
revolución
donde irán entonces que sucedió en la
revolución de irán irán que es un país
pues muy importante en expos en
exportación de petróleo no pudo producir
tanto entonces bajó su producción y una
vez más produjo una crisis petrolera
pero porque estas dos cosas bueno en
estas dos cosas en ambos casos tenemos
que la oferta de petróleo disminuye
verdad pero porque eso causa que esto se
mueva hacia la izquierda pues déjame
escribirle por aquí abajo algo
importante tenemos lo siguiente tenemos
que la oferta de petróleo la oferta de
petróleo disminuyó dramáticamente en
ambas situaciones dramáticamente
entonces qué sucede cuando la oferta de
algo disminuye dramáticamente pues su
precio su precio aumenta también
dramáticamente entonces como estaba más
o menos el contexto en esta época pues
había muchos coches que requerían
gasolina muchas fábricas que requerían
combustible en esa época los coches no
eran tan eficientes las fábricas tampoco
entonces la economía dependía todavía
más fuertemente del petróleo de lo que
depende ahora entonces que empieza a
pasar pues empieza a haber una
alza muy grandota de los costos de los
precios y entonces sucede esto de acá
vamos a la gráfica para allá para ver
cómo podemos interpretar que se desplaza
hacia la izquierda pero mira podemos
pensar en lo siguiente podemos pensar
que para un nivel de productividad fijo
digamos algo de por aquí para un nivel
de productividad fijo ahora los
distribuidores van a cobrar más si antes
cobraban una cierta cantidad por aquí
pero ahora van a cobrar más porque abr
es más caro el petróleo o también de
modo similar podemos pensar qué sucede
con un precio fijo por un precio fijo
ahora vamos a tener aquí este cierta
cierta digamos oferta verdad pero qué va
a pasar pues a ese a ese más bien aquí
estaba la situación original entonces
tenemos una cierta oferta pero por un
precio fijo ahora van a estar dispuestos
a llevar menos verdad producir menos
entonces por un precio fijo tenemos
menos la curva se desplaza hacia la
izquierda o bien por una producción fija
van a querer cobrar más
es decir la curva se desplaza hacia
arriba más o menos podemos pensar que en
ambos casos esto quiere decir que la
curva
se desplaza hacia la izquierda va
entonces qué sucede estas crisis
petroleras lo que hacen es desplazar la
curva hacia la izquierda eso aumenta el
precio verdad hace que tengamos un
precio más alto y no sólo eso no solo
tenemos un precio más alto en este nivel
de equilibrio sino que además tenemos
estanflación hay un estancamiento poder
porque el producto interno bruto real
también disminuye